ils veulent se faire entendre professeur
représentant parents et élus protestent
contre la dotation horaire des
établissements attribué à la rentrée
prochaine alors nous sommes tous
aujourd'hui devant ce collège philippe
de champaigne puisque nous avons reçu il
ya une semaine voire dix jours la
dotation horaire globale pour la mise en
place de la rentrée 2010 9 et il se
trouve qu'elle n'est pas du tout en
adéquation avec les effectifs prévus
l'année prochaine pour la rentrée de
septembre il est prévu des classes de 30
élèves du jamais vu pour ce collège
aujourd'hui on est à peu près à 24 25
élèves par classe et on a un collège
atypique qui est sur deux communes qui
ont deux profils différents sur le mini
saint denis et la verrière avec des
parcours scolaires différents et être à
30 par classe pour eux c'est c'est pas
possible pour alerter sur ses futures
conditions ils arrêtaient les
automobilistes en plus des classes
surchargées les accompagnements
éducatifs sont aussi menacés on craint
également la perte des différents
projets des différents dispositifs qui
nous permettent de faire davantage de
différenciation pédagogique notamment
sur des demi groupes ou sur des projets
science des projets autour du français
des projets interdisciplinaires que l'on
risque de perdre pour l'an prochain est
d hier soir c'est au collège de la
joaillerie l'encours que parents et
professeurs se rassembler sous su
également de la qualité de
l'enseignement dispensé aux enfants on
va essayer aussi de de sensibiliser
davantage les parents qu'ils se rendent
compte que des 30 élèves par classe ça
ne permet pas une différenciation et ça
ne permet pas d'amener les élèves à la
réussite il faut que les parents aussi
en soit conscient ce sont leurs enfants
moi ma fille en 6e donc
pour le moment je sens pas enfin je vois
pas trop l'intérêt pour elles mais je
sais qu'à moyen terme va être concerné
par les deux suppressions de classes
j'ai pas forcément envie que que son
enseignement soit dégradée un mouvement
qui continuera dans l'attenté d'un
rendez vous avec elle la direction
académique des yvelines